da kommen wir auch noch zu einem
wichtigen anderen Thema
und das ist Scopes
und zwar wenn wir so Variablen definieren
die können ja
innerhalb und außerhalb der Funktion
definiert worden sein
und das nennt man Scope
praktisch haben eine andere Zugriff
Berechtigung
oder sind praktisch
nicht immer lesbar
hier zum Beispiel in grün
haben wir unsere globalen
Variablen definiert
warum sind die global
weil die außerhalb unserer definierten Funktion sind
und die können wir dann auch
innerhalb dieser Funktion verwenden
umgekehrt geht aber nicht
also wenn wir hier
hier im Blau zum Beispiel dieses Z definieren
das ist nicht
hier, das können wir nicht
außerhalb verwenden
praktisch nicht lesbar
außerhalb unserer Funktion
das können wir auch kurz testen
probieren wir mal das hier aus
also hier
haben wir unsere 2 globalen
Variablen 4 und 3
dann
printen wir hier Z aus
also die globale Variable Z
dann rufen wir
test.scope
auf
redefinieren wir Z
printen hier
einmal die globale Variable Y
und einmal
diese Funktionsvariable
Z
dann gehen wir wieder raus
aus der Funktion
und dann wollen wir nochmal
Z printen
was glaubt ihr
steht da im letzten Z drin
ist eine Tricksfrage
also es ist so
wir können
globale Variablen lesen
wir können sie aber nicht
überschreiben in praktisch
innerhalb der Funktion
das heißt wenn wir das jetzt ausführen
dann printen wir hier
unsere globale Variable Z
mit dem Bär 3
dann gehen wir in diese Funktion
dort printen wir die
globale Variable Y
weil wir können sie ja lesen
dann
versuchen wir aber hier Z
zu printen
aber wir haben die ja hier in der Funktion
einen neuen Wert zugewiesen
scheint zu mir so
dann gehen wir wieder raus
also das hier ist unsere Funktion
und dann wollen wir nochmal die
globale Variable Z printen
aber die wurde jetzt nicht
überschrieben
weil man in
praktisch innerhalb dieser Funktion
die globale Variable nicht überschreiben kann
das scheint ein bisschen kompliziert zu sein
am Anfang aber es ist
eigentlich eh selbstverständlich
wir können das ja auch nochmal hier ausprobieren
ah was hab ich hier ausprobieren
ich muss ja mal schauen was ich da programmiert hab
jetzt macht nochmal
dasselbe
wie
können wir da zum Beispiel
hergehen und Z
wirklich überschreiben
das geht natürlich
trotzdem
also da gibt es 2
Varianten wie man das machen kann
wir können einerseits sagen
ok wir machen
global Z
also wir wollen ja
wir wollen in dieser Funktion hier Z
die globale Variable
verwenden
dann machen wir einfach
das hier global Z
und dann weiß die Funktion
ok es gibt eine globale Variable Z
die wir in dieser Funktion überschreiben wollen
und da werden wir das jetzt ausführen
tatsächlich
ist hier dann nicht mehr 3 sondern 5
das global
solltet ihr aber nicht verwenden
ihr solltet
lieber sowas machen
und hier kommt dieses return
keyword
wieder ins Spiel
das heißt
wir definieren
hier unseren Variab
unseren Parameter Z
den wir überschreiben wollen
ähm
wir schreiben ihn hier
und dann returnen wir den
und dann machen wir hier einfach Z
ist gleich der Wert der hier rauskommen soll
und dann wird dieser Wert auch wirklich
überschrieben
ähm
genau
das heißt return Z
so wenn wir das hier kurz durchgehen
hier haben wir Z ist gleich 3
dann übergeben wir hier
den Wert 3
in dieser Funktion
also hier
die muss hier nicht Z
das heißt die kann hier auch was anderes heißen
Funktionsintern wird hier nur mit
den Werten gearbeitet
und nicht mit der Variable selber
das heißt hier wird
einfach nur der 3er übergeben
und nicht die Referenz
zu diesem Z
praktisch nicht die
Adresse falls ihr jetzt zurückrennen könnt
aber da kommen wir auch noch
kurz dazu
ähm
genau
und diese Sichtbarkeit
vom Variablen
also
Sichtbarkeit
wir haben ja hier jetzt
W definiert ja
ich kann W außerhalb
der Funktion nicht verwenden
dann bekomme ich so
Gelb
da steht W ist nicht definiert
warum ist das nicht definiert
weil es nicht im selben Kurzblock ist
das hier ist 1 eingerückt
deshalb ist
die Sichtbarkeit ist immer nur in einer Richtung
die geht nicht in beide Richtungen
genau
deshalb
habe ich da auch kurz davor
ähm
dass die Funktionsparameter Z
zu W umgenannt
weil selbe Name
lokal und global ist vermöglich
aber das führt dann zu Problemen
und das sollte man vermeiden
also am besten immer wenn ihr eine Funktion habt
den einen
den Parameter einen anderen Namen geben
wie außerhalb
genau
ja
hier zum Beispiel
was passiert hier
selbe kurz nachschauen
ähm
ok probieren wir das
kurz aus
ok sagen wir wir definieren
hier nicht Z
ähm
und definieren
erst danach
mal mache ich das da oben
das ist ein guter
wenn wir Z hier zum Beispiel
erst danach definieren
also nach dem Funktionsaufruf
aber hier
wir Z verwenden
wollen
dann funktioniert
sich das
im Moment trotzdem
weil wir da noch
ein Clubbitter verwenden
ja der
Clubbitter ist nämlich so
der ähm
kann sich im Hintergrund trotzdem diese Variable ab
ähm
deshalb könntet ihr auch später nochmal
verwenden obwohl sie erst später definiert wird
hier ist es dann so
dass praktisch Z erst nach dem Funktionsaufruf
definiert worden ist
also hier haben wir so
das hier ist ein Nähmauer weil hier
die Variable überhaupt nicht
definiert ist
genau jetzt haben wir es eben so
dass wir hier Z
verwenden wollen
aufs Volk gar nicht existiert
in diesem Fall haben wir
einen Nähmauer
denn Anbau und Local Error
muss ich nochmal nachschauen
warum der kommt
aber ja
genau also
wenn ihr hier in der Funktion
globale Variablen
verwendet
die aber erst nach dem Funktionsaufruf
definiert worden sind
oder in einer anderen Variable
Funktionen definiert worden sind
ähm
wie ihr seht hier
der Scope ist hier zwar identisch
aber das hier ist eine andere Funktion
und die Funktion kann nicht in diese Funktion
reinschauen
ähm
genauso kann
man hier nicht in diese Funktion reinschauen
also
ich kann nur von dem
nach außen schauen
genau das wäre eigentlich
schon das hier
ich weiß es ist jetzt ein bisschen komplizierter
soll ich da noch ein Beispiel machen
oder wollte
ähm
das ist eine Variable
das ist jetzt das erste
simples Beispiel also man kann sich da jetzt
natürlich denken
ok
zeige ich euch mal kurz ein anderes Beispiel her
schauen wir mal ob ich da eins hab
da oben glaube ich ist ja sehr gut
ja stell euch vor ihr habt so ein
Codeblock hier
ich hab hier ähm
praktisch die schauen ja sehr
sehr ähnlich aus oder
also wir haben hier praktisch hier nur
First and Last Name wo wir praktisch diese
Variable Namen verändern
aber zum Beispiel hier
dieses Full Name Punkt Title
und das Print Full Name das bleibt eigentlich immer identisch
für so was zum Beispiel ist es ultra nice
wenn man eine Funktion hat
oder was mache ich
ich warte, ich werde das euch da kurz mal
einfach so machen
und die Bekommt First
und Last
da haben wir unseren Code
drin
da müssen wir natürlich auch wieder
schauen, dass die Einrückung passt
dann
das ist der Code
und das kann man diese Full Name
Funktion immer wieder
verwenden aber mit anderen
Parametern das heißt
hier haben wir unsere 4, 5, 6
verschiedene Schauspiele
die wir hier alle nacheinander
ausgeben wollen
hier ist es so, dass wir das Ganze
dann einfach wirklich so machen können
Und das kann man dann zum Beispiel kombinieren mit Schleifen nicht, also das kann ich dann
auch noch kurz zeigen.
Ah, okay ja, muss ich zuerst das hier machen?
Okay, praktisch kann diese Funktion mehrmals aufrufen, da kann ich zum Beispiel sage ich
habe eine Berechnung, die ich immer wieder machen muss, dann habe ich mir diese Berechnung
hier in eine eigene Funktion rein und da kann ich die immer wieder aufrufen.